good afternoon
i'm forrest buck mayor of ottawa
in a few minutes i will go into the
character as mayor joseph o glover from
the year 1858
first though it is my great pleasure to
welcome you to ottawa and to washington
park
site of the first lincoln douglas debate
the debate was of such significance that
washington park is now listed on the
national historic register of historic
places of the national park service
i would also like to note now that the
symposium going on over at the
courthouse is open for anyone free who
wishes to go ahead sometime later on
today and attend this symposium
in the main
lincoln and douglas debated three issues
the extension of slavery
the status of the negro
and the right of the states to regulate
the status of the negro as they saw fit
only the first was settled by the civil
war
the other two are as pressing today as
they were then
the debate lasted for three hours with
douglas speaking first for one hour
lincoln responding for one and a half
hour
and douglas reputing for another hour
this afternoon we are reenacting the
debate in its entirety
its length may seem tedious
to our 20th century ears and seats
however we are faithfully reenacting an
important piece of history
from a time when the chance to see and
hear such prominent men
was a rare and exciting event that
justified both the time spent in the
debate and the hours sacrificed in the
effort
finally one last word
as a 20th century mayor i feel i must
point out that each actor on the stage
and each costumed lincoln or douglas
supporter planted among you
is simply playing a role
the cheers and responses you will hear
from the crowd are the most accurate
recreation
of the original crowd reaction that we
can do
we ask that you join in the spirit of
the occasion adding your voices from
time to time and cheering
your particular speakers
and now as joseph glover
mayor of the fair city of ottawa in the
campaign year of 1858 i'm pleased to
welcome
to this great debate and to welcome our
opposing candidates
my good friend abraham lincoln
[Applause]
thank you
thank you
thank you
thank you sit down sit down
please be seated
sit down
[Applause]
we are gathered here for the first of
seven debates
these debates are already attracting
nationwide attention we have reporters
from chicago new york philadelphia and
other places in the united states
it took some doing but now that we have
our honored guests and leading citizens
in their rightful places it is my
privilege to introduce the platform
platform party to you
of course we have mr lincoln and senator
douglas we also have mr john
fisk nash
mr john manley
mr b c cook
mr william cogswell
major william wallace
and the honorable congressman
mr owen lovejoy
mr william reddick
mr william cushman
mr washington bush now
and our
this is it
our indian brother
chief shabana has joined us although he
was not expected we're very pleased that
the chief was able to come this
afternoon
i know that mr douglas and mr lincoln
will debate the great issues of our time
with vigor and conviction
senator douglas will speak first
followed by a response from mr lincoln
senator douglas will then have the
opportunity for a brief rebuttal
mr cushman will introduce senator
douglas and later mr nash will introduce
my good friend mr abraham lincoln mr
cushman you may now introduce your
candidate
distinguished guests
and fellow citizens
it is my great honor
to represent the democratic
party today and to have the pleasure of
introducing
senator stephen
arnold
douglas
candidate his candidate for the united
states senate
and president chairman of the united
states committee on territories
in 1854
senators senator douglas's committee
reported the now famous
kansas nebraska bill
it established the essential principle
of sovereign
popular sovereignty
allowing the people of the territories
to decide for themselves
the issue of slavery
senator douglas
achieved the passage of this important
legislation
by virtue of diligent
hard
work
among his colleagues
and exceptionally brilliant floor
leadership
without his dedication and support
this bill would never have been passed
and that cornerstone
of freedom and right of the individual
states to choose would have been greatly
eroded
ladies and gentlemen
i know that senator douglas will stir
through your hearts today
as he defends the great principles of
democracy
we owe
senator douglas our vote
and our eternal gratitude
i count it a great
privilege
and a rare opportunity
to present to you
one of the country's great
men
senator
stephen
a
douglas
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
i appear before you today
for the purpose of discussing the
leading political topics which now
agitate the public mind
this
this vast concourse of people shows the
deep feeling which pervades the masses
in regard to this question
by mean
by an arrangement previously made
we have today a joint discussion between
mr lincoln
and myself
as the representatives of the two great
political parties in the state
and union
prior to 1854
this country was divided into two great
political parties known as the whig
and democratic parties
both national and democratic in their
principles both advocating principles
which were
universal in their application
an old line wig could proclaim his
principles in louisiana
and massachusetts alike
wig principles were not limited by the
ohio river nor by the potomac nor by the
line of free enslaved states
but applied and were proclaimed wherever
the constitution ruled or the american
flag waved over american soil
[Applause]
so it was
and so it is with the principles
of the great
democratic party
which from the days of jefferson until
this period
had proven itself to be
the historical party of this nation
while the whig in the democratic parties
differed in regard to a bank
in regard to a tariff in regard to
distribution and in regard to the
species circular and in regard to the
sub-treasury they agreed
on the great question that now agitates
the union known as the slavery question
while they differed on those other
matters of expediency
to which i have referred
the whig party
and the democratic party
jointly adopted the compromise measures
of 1850
as the basis of the solution of the
slavery question in all of its forms
clay was the great leader with webster
on his right and louis chaos on his left
sustained by the patriots in the whig
and democratic ranks in devising and
adopting and enacting the compromise
measures of 1850
again
in 1851 in illinois
the whig party and the democratic party
united in resolutions endorsing and
improving
the compromise measures of 1850 as the
proper
adjustment of this question
in 1852
when the whig party assembled at
baltimore for the purpose of nominating
its candidate for the presidency
the first thing it did
was to adopt the compromise measures of
1850 in substance and in principle as
the satisfactory adjustment of that
question
my friends
my friends silence
is more acceptable to me
in the discussion of this question than
applause
i desire to address myself to your
judgment to your
understanding to your consciences
and not
to your passions
i was saying
when the democratic convention assembled
in baltimore in 1852
for the purpose of nominating a
candidate to the presidency
they also adopted the compromise
measures of 1850
as the basis of democratic action
thus you see
that up to
1853
1854
the whig party and the democratic party
both stood
on the same platform in regard to the
slavery question which now
agitates this country
that platform
was the right of the people of each
state and of each territory to decide
their local
and domestic institutions for themselves
subject only to the federal constitution
at the session of 1853 1853-54
i introduced into the senate of the
united states a bill to organize the
territories of kansas and nebraska on
that principle
which had been adopted in the compromise
measures of 1850 approved by the whig
party and the democratic party and the
democratic party in illinois in 1851
and endorsed by the whig party in the
democratic party in the national
conventions of 1852.
now
in order that there might be no
misunderstanding in regard to the
principle
involved in the kansas and nebraska bill
i put forth
the true intent
and meaning of the act
in these words
it being the true intent and meaning of
this act
not to legislate slavery into any state
or territory not
to excluded they're from
but to leave the people thereof
perfectly free to form and regulate
their domestic institutions in their own
way
subject only to the federal constitution
thus
you see
that up to 1854 when the kansas and
nebraska bill was brought into congress
for the purpose of carrying out the
principles which up to that time both
parties had endorsed and approved
there had been no division of this
country in regard to that principle
except the
opposition of the abolitionists
in the illinois legislature in the house
of representatives upon the resolution
asserting that principle
every whig
and every democrat in the house voted
for that principle only four men voted
against it and those four men were old
line abolitionists
[Applause]
in 1854
mr
abraham lincoln and mr lyman trumbull
entered into an arrangement
one with the other
and each with their respective friends
to dissolve the old whig party on one
hand and to dissolve the old democratic
party on the other hand
and convert the members of both parties
into an abolitionist party under the
name
of the republican party
the terms of that arrangement between mr
lincoln
and mr trumbull have been published to
the world by mr lincoln's special friend
mr james h matheny
which was
which was that mr lincoln was to have
general james shields place
then about to become vacant in the
united states senate
and mr trumbull
wants to have
my place
oh mr lincoln went to work industriously
to abolitionize the old wig party all
over the state pretending that he was as
good a wig
as ever he was
trumbull went to work in his part of the
state down in egypt preaching
abolitionism
in a milder
and a lighter form of not quite so dark
a color
but yet trying to abolitionize the
democratic party and bring the old
democrats handcuffed
hand in foot into the abolition camp
in pursuance of that arrangement
the parties met at springfield in
october 1854
and proclaimed their new platform mr
lincoln was to bring into the abolition
camp the old line wigs
and transfer them over to josh r
giddings and sam and p chase and fred
douglas
owen lovejoy and john f farnsworth who
were then ready to receive and christian
them into abolitionists
[Applause]
they laid down on that occasion a
platform for this new
republican party
which was to be constructed out of the
old whig party in the old democratic
party by
abolitionizing both and transferring
them into
abolitionism
have
the resolutions of that convention which
was the first mass state convention ever
held in illinois by the republican party
i
i now hold them in my hand and will read
a part of the resolutions
and cause the others to be printed
now
here is one of the resolutions and the
most material one of this abolition
platform under the new name of
republicanism
to
resolve
that the times imperatively demand the
reorganization of the parties
and repudiating all previous party
attachments names and prediligence
we unite ourselves together
in defense of the liberty and
constitution of the country
and will hereafter cooperate as the
republican party
pledged to the accomplishment of the
following purposes
to bring administration of the
government back to control first
principles to restore nebraska and
kansas to the position of free
territories
that is the constitution of the united
states vests in the states and not in
congress
the power to legislate for the
extradition of fugitives from labor
to repeal and entirely abrogate the
fugitive slave law
to restrict slavery to those states in
which it exists
to prohibit the admission of any more
slave states
into the union
to abolish slavery in the district of
columbia
to exclude slavery from all the
territories over which the general
government has exclusive jurisdiction
and to resist the acquirements of any
more territories unless the practice of
slavery therein forever shall have been
prohibited
[Applause]
now gentlemen you have cheered
you republicans have cheered every one
of these propositions
and yet
i venture to say you cannot get mr
lincoln your candidate to come out and
say that he is now for each one of them
that these propositions do one and all
constitute the platform of the black
republican party this day i have no
doubt
and when you were not aware for what
purpose i was reading these resolutions
you cheered them as good black
republican doctrine
[Applause]
and yet my object in reading them is to
put the question to abraham lincoln this
day
whether he now stands and will stand by
each article of that creed and carry
them all out
i desire to know
whether mr lincoln today stands pledged
as he did in 1854
in favor
of the unconditional repeal
of the fugitive slave law
i desire him to answer
whether he stands pledged today as he
did in 54
against the admission of any more slave
states
even
if the people want them i want to know
if he stan's pledged to vote against the
admission of a new state into the union
with such a constitution as the people
that state may see fit to make
[Applause]
[Music]
i desire to know whether he stands
pledge today
to the abolition of slavery in the
district of columbia
and i desire to know whether he stands
pledge to abolish and prohibit the slave
trade between the different states
i desire to know
whether he stands pledged to prohibit
slavery in all the territories of the
united states north as well as south of
the missouri compromise line kansas too
i desire him to answer
whether he is opposed to the acquisition
of any more territory
unless slavery is prohibited therein
i
want his answer
your affirmative cheers in favor of this
abolition platform are not satisfactory
i want abraham lincoln to answer these
questions in order that when i try him
down to lower egypt i may compel him to
repeat the same
[Applause]
my
my principles are the same
everywhere
i can proclaim them alike in the north
in the south and in the east and the
west
my principles will apply
wherever the constitution prevails and
the american flag waves over american
territory
i desire to know whether mr lincoln's
principles will bear to be transplanted
transplanted from ottawa to jonesboro
i put these questions to him today
and ask an answer
i have a right to an answer upon these
for i quote them from the platform of
the republican party
the platform made by himself and others
at the time the republican party was
first formed
and the bargain was made to dissolve and
kill off and destroy the old wig and
democratic parties
and transfer each of their members bound
hand and foot into the abolition party
under the directions of giddings and
chase
in the remarks which i have made upon
this platform
and the positions of mr lincoln upon it
i mean nothing personal
disrespectful
or unkind to that gentleman
i have known him for nearly 25
years we had many points of sympathy
when i first got acquainted with him
we were both comparatively boys both
struggling with poverty in a strange
land for our support
i
and humble school teacher in the town of
winchester
and he
a flourishing grocery
keeper
grocery keeper in the town of salem
he was more successful in his occupation
than i
and thus became
far more fortunate in this works goods
mr lincoln
is one of those peculiar men
that has performed with admirable skill
in every occupation
that he ever attempted
i made as good a school teacher as i
could
and when a cabinet maker
i made the best bed stands and tables
but my old bones said i succeeded better
in bureaus and secretaries than in
anything else
[Applause]
but i believe that mr lincoln was more
successful in his business than i
for his business soon carried him
directly into the legislature
there i met him in a little time and i
had a sympathy for him because of the
uphill struggle that we had in life
he was then
as good at telling an anecdote as now no
doubt he could beat any of the boys at
wrestling
could outrun them at a foot race beat
them at pitching points and tossing a
copper
and he could win more liquor than all
the boys put together
and the dignity
and impartiality with which he presided
in a horse race or a fistfight where the
praise of everybody that was present and
participated
[Applause]
i had sympathy for him
because he was struggling with
misfortune
and so was i
mr lincoln served with me
or i
with him
in the legislature of 1836 when we
parted
he
subsided or submerged for some years and
i lost sight of him
in 1846 when david wilmot raised the
wilmot proviso tornado
mr lincoln again
turned up
as a member of congress from sagamon
district
i
being in the senate of the united states
was called to welcome him then without
friend and companion
he
he then distinguished himself
by his opposition to the mexican war
taking the side of the common enemy in
time of war against his own country
when when he returned home from that
congress
he found that the indignation of the
people followed him everywhere
until he again
retired to private life
and was submerged until he was forgotten
again by his friends
he came up again in 1854
just in time for the abolition black
republican platform
in the company of lovejoy giddings chase
and fred douglas for the republican
party to stand upon
[Applause]
trumbull
two
was one of our own contemporaries
he was born and raised in old
connecticut
bred a federalist he removed to georgia
and there turned noah fire when
nullification was popular but as soon as
he disposed of his clocks and wound up
his business he emigrated to illinois
when
when he got here
having turned politician and lawyer
he made his appearance in 1840 41
as a member of the legislature
and became noted
as the author of a scheme
to repudiate a large portion of the
state debt of illinois
and thus bring infamy and disgrace upon
the fair discussion of our glorious
state the odium
attached to that measure consigned him
to oblivion for a time
i walked into the house of
representatives and replied to his
repudiation speeches until we carried
resolutions over his head denouncing
repudiation and asserting the moral and
the legal obligation of illinois to pay
every dollar of debt she owed every bond
bearing her signature
[Applause]
malignity towards me
arises out of the fact that i defeated
his infamous scheme to repudiate the
state debt and state bonds of illinois
now
these two men
having formed this combination to
abolitionize the old whig party and
abolitionize the old democratic party
and put themselves in the senate in
pursuance of the bargain with each other
are now
carrying out that arrangement
matheny states that the bargain was made
i understand it from others and i
suppose lincoln will not deny it
the bargain was
with lincoln was to have the place of
shields in the senate and trumbull was
to wait for me
the story goes
that trumbull cheated lincoln at that
time
now trumbull having control of four or
five abolition democrats who were
holding over in the senate
would not let them vote for lincoln and
forced the abolition whigs to go over to
trumbull thus cheating lincoln out of
his part of the bargain
now
lincoln desires that he shall have the
place then designed for trumbull as
trumbull cheated him and got his place
and trouble is now stumping the state
introducing me
for the purpose of securing that
position to mr lincoln in order to quiet
him lincoln can never
that accounts for the fact that the
republican convention were compelled
compelled to instruct for lincoln and
nobody else when they nominated him
they had to pass a resolution that
lincoln was the first choice of the
republican party
archie williams was nowhere orville
browning was nobody john wentworth was
not worthy of notice norman judd was not
to be considered they had
nobody else in the republican party
except lincoln
for the reason that lincoln demanded
that they should carry out the
arrangement
hence
hence
having formed this new party for the
joint benefit of deserters from wigary
and deserters from democracy having laid
down the abolition platform which i have
read
lincoln now takes the stand
and proclaims his abolition doctrine
let me read a part of it
in his speech to the convention which
nominated him for the senate in
springfield he says
in my opinion the slavery agitation will
not cease
till a crisis shall have been reached
and passed
a house divided against itself cannot
stand i believe this government cannot
endure permanently half slave and half
free
i do not expect the union to be
dissolved
i do not expect the house to fall
but i expect it will cease to be divided
it will become all one thing or all the
other
either the opponents of slavery will
arrest the further spread of it
and place it where the public mind shall
rest in the belief that it is in the
course of ultimate extinction
or its advocates will push it forward
until it shall become alike lawful in
all the states old as well as new north
as well as south
oh good yes i have no doubt it is and i
am delighted delighted to hear you say
good
i have no doubt
that doctrine expresses your sentiments
and yet i will prove to you if you will
listen to me
that doctrine is revolutionary
and destructive
of the existence of our government
[Applause]
mr lincoln uh here says that our
government cannot endure permanently in
the same condition
in which it was made by its framers
it was made divided into free states and
slave states
mr lincoln says it had existed for near
80 years thus divided but
he tells you that it cannot endure
permanently on the same principles
and in the same conditions relatively in
which your fathers made it neither can
it
why
can't it endure divided into free
enslaved states
washington as the president of the
convention
franklin and madison and hamilton and
jay and the patriots of that day made
this government divided into free states
and slave states leaving each state
perfectly free to do as it pleased on
that subject of slavery
why
can't
it exist upon the same principles
upon which
our fathers made it
our fathers knew when they made this
government
that in a country as broad and wide as
this
with such a variety of climate of
interest of productions is this
that the people necessarily required
different local laws
and local institutions in certain
localities from those in other
localities
they knew that the laws and regulations
that would suit the granite hills of new
hampshire would be unsuited to the rice
plantations of south carolina
hence they provided
that each state
should retain its own legislature
and its own sovereignty
with the full and complete power to do
as it pleased within its own limits in
all that was local
and not national
one of the reserved rights of the states
was that of regulating the relation
between master and slave
or
the slavery question at that time
that is when the constitution was made
there were 13 states in the union 12
of which were slave states and one was a
free state now suppose this doctrine of
uniformity all to be won or all to be
another now preached by mr lincoln had
prevailed then
what would have been the result
uh of course the 12 slave holding states
would have overruled the one free state
and slavery would have been fastened by
a constitutional provision
over every inch of the american
continent instead of being left
as our fathers wisely left it
for each state to decide for itself
[Applause]
i therefore say
the uniformity in the local laws and
local legislation of the different
states
was neither possible
nor desirable
if any uniformity had been adopted
it must inevitably have been the
uniformity of slavery everywhere or the
uniformity of negro citizenship and
negro equality everywhere
we
we are told by lincoln
that he is utterly opposed
to the dred scott decision and will not
submit to it for the reason as he says
that it deprives
the negro
of the rights
and privileges
of citizenship
there is the first and main reason he
says
for his warfare upon the supreme court
of the united states that it deprives
the negro of the rights
and privileges
of citizenship
now
i ask you
are you
in favor of conferring upon the negro
the rights and privileges of citizenship
do you desire to strike out of our state
constitution that clause which keeps me
slaves and freeny grows out of the state
and allow the free negro to flow in
and cover our prairies with his
settlements do you desire to turn this
beautiful state into a free negro colony
and in order that when missouri shall
abolish slavery she can send us these
emancipated slaves to become citizens
and voters on an equality with you
[Applause]
if you desire negro citizenship if you
desire them to come into the state and
stay with white men if you desire to let
them vote on an equality with yourselves
if you desire to make them eligible for
office to have them serve on juries and
judge of your rights then go with mr
lincoln and the black republicans in
favor of negro citizenship
[Applause]
for one
i am opposed to negro citizenship in any
way or form
i believe that this government was made
on the white basis
i believe that it was made by white men
for the benefit of white men and for
their posterity forever
and
i am in favor of confining the
citizenship to white men men of european
birth and european descent instead of
conferring and upon negroes and indians
and other inferior races
[Applause]
mr lincoln
following the lead of the abolition
orators that have come here and lectured
in the basements of your churches and
schoolhouses
reads the declaration of independence
that all men are created free and equal
and then says
how can you deprive the negro that
equality which god and the declaration
of independence awards to him
he
and they maintain that negro equality is
guaranteed by the laws of god and
reasserted in the declaration of
independence now if they think so
they ought thus to say
and thus to vote
i
do not question
mr lincoln's conscientious belief
that the negro was made his equal and
thus his brother
but
but for my own part
i do not regard the negro as my equal
and i positively deny
that he is my brother
or any kin to me whatsoever
[Applause]
but he has learned love joy's catechism
can repeat it as well as farnsworth and
could receive baptism from father
giddings or fred douglas on abolitionism
he holds
that the negro was endowed with equality
by the almighty
and hence that no human power alone
can deprive him of these rights which
the almighty has guaranteed to him
i do not believe the almighty ever
intended the negro to be the equal of
the white man
if he did he's been a long time in
demonstrating the fact
for six thousand years
the negro has been a race upon the earth
and during that whole six thousand years
in all latitudes and climates wherever
the negro has been
he has been the inferior to whatever
race had joined him
the fact is
he belongs to an inferior race and must
occupy an inferior position
[Applause]
now
i do not hold that merely because the
negro belongs to an inferior race
therefore he ought to be a slave
by no means can such a conclusion be
drawn
on the contrary
i hope that humanity and christianity
both require
that the negro should have and enjoy
every right every privilege and every
immunity consistent
with the society
in which he lives
on
on that point i presume there can be no
diversity of opinion
you and i are bound to extend to every
inferior dependent being
every right
every privilege in every facility and
immunity consistent
with the public good
then then the question arises
what rights and privileges
are consistent with the public good now
that is a question that each state in
each territory must decide for itself
now illinois
has decided that question for herself
we in illinois
have provided that the negro shall not
become a slave
we have also provided that he shall not
be a citizen bob
we protect him in his civil rights in
his life
in his person in his property while we
deprive him of any political right
whatsoever and refuse to treat him on an
equality with the white man
[Applause]
that policy of illinois
is satisfactory to me
if it were to the republicans
then there would be no question on the
subject
but
the republicans say that the negro ought
to be made a citizen
and when he becomes a citizen
he becomes your equal in all rights and
privileges of citizenship
they assert
that the dreads dred scott decision
was wicked and monstrous
because it denies that a negro is or can
be a citizen
under the constitution
now i hold that illinois had a right to
abolish and prohibit slavery as she did
but i hold that kentucky has the same
right to continue and protect slavery
that illinois has to abolish it i hold
that new york had as much a ride to
abolish slavery as virginia has to
continue it i hold that each and every
state of the union is a sovereign power
with the right to do as it pleases on
this question of slavery and in all
domestic institutions
but
slavery is not the only domestic
relation that comes upon this
controversy
the question is far more important to
you
what
shall be done for the free negro
now we have settled the slavery question
as far as we are concerned
we have prohibited it
in illinois forever
in doing so i think we have done wisely
and there is no man in the state who
would be more strenuous in his
opposition to the introduction of
slavery than i would
but when we have settled it for
ourselves
we have exhausted all our power over the
subject we have done
our whole duty we have no right to go
further
but we must leave each
and every other state
to decide for itself beyond our limits
then the question arises what shall be
our policy in regard to free negroes
we
have said
they shall not vote
the state of maine
says that free negroes
may vote
maine is a sovereign state
has the power to regulate the
qualifications within her limits
while i would not be in favor of
conferring the rights of citizenship
upon free negroes in our state yet
i shall not quarrel with the state of
maine
because it differs from me
in opinion
let
mane take care of her own negroes and
let illinois alone and we will let the
state of maine alone
so so with the state of new york
she allows
the free negro to vote and hold office
provided he owns 250 dollars worth of
property but not otherwise
while i would make no distinction
between a negro who held property and
one who did not yet if the sovereign
state of new york judges to make that
distinction it is
her business
and not mine
i will not quarrel with her if she does
this she may do as she pleases upon this
question and mind her own business and
we will do the same
now
now my friends if we will only act
rigidly
and conscientiously upon that great
principle of popular sovereignty
which guarantees to each state
and each territory the right to do as it
pleases instead of congress interfering
we will be at peace
one
with another
why should illinois be at war with
missouri
or kentucky with ohio or virginia with
new york merely because their
institutions differ
our fathers intended that these
institutions should differ
our fathers knew that the south and the
north
so far apart differing in climate and
production
had different interests requiring
different institutions
this
doctrine of uniformity of mr lincoln's
making all of them conform alike
is a new doctrine never dreamed of by
washington or madison or the framers of
the constitution
mr lincoln
and the republican party set themselves
up
as wiser
than those who made the government
now this government has flourished for
70 years upon the principle of popular
sovereignty recognizing the right of
each state to do as it pleases
under that principle we have grown up
from three or four millions to about 30
millions of people under that principle
we have crossed the allegheny mountains
and filled up the whole northwest
turning the prairie into a garden
building up cities and towns and
churches and schools and spreading
civilization and christianity where
before there was nothing but savage
barbarism
under that principle we have become from
a feeble nation the most powerful nation
on the face of the earth if we still
only obey that principle we can go
forward increasing in territory
increasing in power in strength and
glory until the republic of america
shall be the north star that shall guide
the prince of freedom throughout the
civilized world
[Applause]
then
friends
why can we not adhere to that great
principle of self-government
upon which our institutions were
originally made
we can
i believe
that this new doctrine preached by mr
lincoln and this
abolition party
would dissolve the union
they try to array all the northern
states in one body against the south
inviting a sectional war of the free
states against the slave states
northern states against the southern
states to last until one or the other
shall be driven
to
the wall
i am told that my time is out
you will now hear mr lincoln for an hour
and a half and then myself for a half an
hour in reply
[Applause]
fellow countrymen
i first met abraham lincoln in 1846 when
he was a candidate for congress in the
sangemon district
in 1854 it was my pleasure to meet him
again at the state fair
and in 1856 mr lincoln was at the
convention held to organize the
republican party
and put forth a platform for the
presidential election to follow
in recent days i have become even more
impressed by abraham lee lincoln
and all that he stands for
in today's chicago press and tribune
they praised mr lincoln for i quote his
eulogy of the declaration of
independence that stands as one of the
high points of the campaign
[Applause]
he delivers this during defense of the
declaration of independence just four
days ago in lewistown reminding the
people of lewistown that the framers of
the declaration held these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal
that they are endowed by their creator
with certain unalienable rights that
among these are life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness
it is the threat to these truths that
inspires mr lincoln to run for this
senate seat
and it is the preservation of these
ideals
so basic
to the founders of this great nation
that brings mr lincoln to ottawa
into this historic moment
ladies and gentlemen
it is my great privilege and pleasure
to introduce your republican candidate
for united states senator
mr abraham lincoln
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
please please do not take up my time
[Applause]
my fellow citizens
when a man hears himself misrepresented
just a little
while to provoke him
but when he finds that the reference
best of representation is very gross
it's more apt to amuse him
the first thing i find to mention on
this occasion that judge douglas has
mentioned is the fact that he alleges
that judge trumbull made an arrangement
in 1854
by which i was to have the place of
shields in the united states senate
and judge trump always have judge
douglas's place
well
all i have to say is
judge douglas cannot prove that
because it is not true
nor nothing like it
that was right
i have no doubt
that he is conscientious in saying so
again and i'm not going to waste much
time on these affairs
but as to those resolutions that he said
tooks like the time to read as the
platform of the republican party in 1854
i never had anything to do with them
and i think trump will never had
anything to do with them
and judge douglas cannot show that we
ever did have either one of us
now
i believe that this is true about those
resolutions
there was a call for a convention to
form a republican party in springfield
i think my friend lovejoy who is here
with me on the stand had a hand in it
i think that that is so
and i think if he will remember
correctly that he tried me to get into
it
and i would not do it
well i also believe it is true that as i
went from springfield when the
convention was in session
i did not remain
but i went to attend a court in tazewell
county
they had placed my name without any
authority on the committee
and they wrote me to attend the
convention and i would not do it
this is the plain truth of the whole
thing
now all of these stories about trouble
bargaining to sell out the old big
democratic party
and wig and lincoln selling out the old
wig party
well i have the means of knowing about
that
and douglas may not have the means of
knowing about it and there is nothing of
it in the world
i have no doubt
i have no doubt that judge douglas is
very conscientious
about it
i know that after this when mr trump mr
lovejoy got into the legislature he
complained to me that i had told him
that there were old wigs in our party
and if the old rigs were good enough for
us to vote for
and that some of them had voted against
him
a man cannot prove a negative at all
but he has the right to ask the man who
asserts a case of state of the case to
prove it
ice cannot introduce testimony to show
the negative of this thing
but i have the right to claim that the
man who says he knows these things
that he should say how he knows them
it is not exactly satisfactory to me
because he may be conscientious in it
that's right
now i i hate to waste my time on such
things but on the abolition tilt that
the judge thinks i was engaged in
i hope you will permit me to read a part
of a speech that i made in peoria that
will show an altogether different state
of case
put on your specs
well yes sir i'm obliged to
i'm not a young man anymore too young to
get into the senate
this
is the repeal of the missouri compromise
the foregoing history may not be
precisely accurate in every particular
but i am sure that it is sufficiently so
for all the uses i shall attempt to make
of it
and in it we have before us
the chief material enabling us to judge
correctly whether the repeal of the
missouri compromise is right
or wrong
i think
and shall try to show that it is wrong
wrong in its direct effect
letting slavery into kansas nebraska
and wrong in its perspective principle
allowing it to spread to every other
part of the wide world
where men can be found inclined to take
it
this declared indifference
but as i must think covert real zeal for
the spread of slavery
i cannot but hate
i hate it because of the monstrous
injustice of slavery itself
i hate it because it deprives our
republican example
of the just influence in the world
it enables the enemies of the free
institutions
with plausibility
to taunt us as hypocrites
it causes the real friends of freedom to
doubt our sincerity
and especially because it forces so many
good men amongst ourselves
into an open war with the very
fundamental principles of civil liberty
criticizing the declaration of
independence
and insisting that there is no right
principle of action
but
self-interest before proceeding let me
say that i have no prejudice against the
southern people
they are just what we would be in their
situation
if slavery did not now exist among them
they would not introduce it
if it did now exist amongst us
we should not instantly give it up
this i believe of the masses north and
south
doubtless there are individuals on both
sides who would not hold slaves under
any circumstances
and others who had gladly introduce
slavery anew if it had gone out of
existence
we know that some southern men do free
their slaves
go north and become tip-top
abolitionists
while
we know that some northern men go south
and become the most cruel slave masters
when the southern people tell us that
they are no more responsible for the
origin of slavery than we
i acknowledge the fact when it is said
that the institution exists and that it
is very difficult to get rid of it in
any satisfactory way
i understand and appreciate the saying
i certainly would not blame them for not
doing what i should not be able to know
what to do myself
if all earthly power given to me
i should know not why i should not know
what to do
as to the existing
institution
my first impulse would be to free all
the slaves send them to liberia to their
own native land
but a moment's reflection would convince
me that whatever high hopes as i think
there is that there may be in this
in the long run that sudden execution is
impossible
if they were landed there in a day they
would all perish in the next 10 days
and there is not sufficient shipping and
sufficient money in the enough in the
world
to carry them many times
them days
what then
free them all and keep them among us as
underlings
is it quite certain that this better
their condition
i think that i would not hold one in
slavery at any rate
yet the point is not clear enough for me
to denounce people upon
what next
free them and make them are political
and social equals
my own feelings will not admit of this
and if mine would
we well know that those of the great
masses of the white people will not
whether
whether this feeling accords with
justice and sound judgment is not the
sole question
if indeed it's any part of it
a universal feeling
whether well or ill-founded cannot be
safely disregarded
we cannot then make them our equals
it does seem to me that a system of
gradual emancipation might be adopted
but for their tardies in this i do not
undertake to judge my brethren in the
south
and when they remind us of their
constitutional rights
i acknowledge them
i acknowledge them not grudgingly but
fully and fairly
and i would give to them any legislation
for the reclaiming of their fugitives
which should not in its stringency
be more likely to carry a free man into
slavery
than our own ordinary criminal laws are
to hang an innocent one
but all of this to my judgment furnishes
no more excuse for permitting slavery to
go into our own free territory
than it would be for reviving the
african slave trade by law
the law which forbids the bringing of
slaves from africa
and which has so long forbid the taking
of them to nebraska
can hardly be distinguished on any moral
principle and the repeal of the former
could find quite as a plausible excuse
as that
of the latter
now
after all the judges said of me the
the judge heard me make that speech
he heard me make that speech four years
ago
i
i may be right or wrong but
i've never departed from it
right
and i follow on to say that my own
feelings will not permit of this
that i told the judge four years ago
i think the judge has some reason to
know that i was not engaged in an
abolition tilt
but i do not mean that the judge
can catechize me
i will have one for one with a time for
original ones but here one slips out and
i've answered it before mine comes and
he has got mine without me getting one
he has my answer to the fugitive slave
law
again when they remind me
that they are no more responsible for
the existence of slavery than myself
i acknowledge their truth
but in all of this to my judgment
furnishes no more excuse for permitting
slavery
to go into our own free territory than
it would be for reviving the african
slave trade by law
the law which forbids the bringing of
slaves from africa
and which has so long forbid the taking
of slaves to nebraska
can hardly be distinguished on any moral
principle
indeed i deny that they can
be extinguished at all
the repeal of the former could find just
as many excuses of that of the latter
now these are my viewpoints on the whole
subject upon the institution of slavery
and any system of argumentation that
says anything
or argues me into the ideal of a perfect
social and political quality of the
negro
is a species of fantastic arrangement by
of words
by which a man could prove a horse
chestnut to be a chestnut horse
i
i will say here while i'm up on this
subject that i have no purpose directly
or indirectly to interfere with
institutions
in this institution of slavery in the
states where it exists
i believe i have no lawful right to do
so
and i have no lincoln nation to do so
i have no disposition to introduce
political and social equality between
the white and the black races
there is a physical difference between
the two
which in my judgment will probably ever
forbid their living together on terms of
respect
social and political equality
and in so much as it becomes a necessity
there must be a superiority somewhere
i as well as judge douglas am in favor
of the race to which i belong having the
superior position
but i hold that because of this
all of this there is no reason at all
furnished why the negro after all
is not entitled to all that the
declaration of independence holds out
which is life
liberty
and the pursuit of happiness
[Applause]
and i hope
that he is as much entitled to that
as the white man
i agree that the negro may not be my
equal and judge douglas is equal in many
respects
certainly not in color
and in intellectual development perhaps
but in the right to eat the bread which
his own hand earns
he
is my equal
and he is the equal of judge douglas
and he is the equal of every living man
[Applause]
now one or two of these other little
matters and i will pass on
the judge is woefully at fault again
about his early friend being a grocery
keeper
i don't know that would have been a
great sin if i had been but lincoln
never kept a grocery in his life
well it is true that lincoln did work
the latter part of well one winter at a
little still house at the head of the
hollow
[Laughter]
and so i think the judge is equally at
fault when he charges me that when i was
in congress of having opposed the
mexican war
now the judge doesn't make this charge
very distinctly he rather insinuates it
but i can tell you how it was
whenever the democratic party tried to
get me to vote that the war had been
properly begun
it could not do it
but when they asked me to give money or
supplies or land warrants to the
soldiers i have the same votes as judge
douglas for he was in the other branch
now you may think as you please as to
whether i was consistent but when he
insinuates that i withheld my boat or
did anything to hinder the soldiers he
is mistaken altogether as an
investigation of the record would show
i will state since i i haven't used as
much time as i thought i had
perhaps i will dwell a little bit longer
on some two or three of these little
other topics that the judge has spoken
of
he has read from my speech in
springfield where i said a house divided
against itself cannot stand
does the judge say that it can
i don't know the judge doesn't seem to
be attending to me right now
but i would like to know what his
opinion is if it can
and if so that raises a question of
veracity
and it is not a question of arrest
between the judge and myself
but the judge has a question of veracity
with a somewhat higher character than
myself
it is not a question between him and me
and now i ask your attention to that
matter for the purpose of saying
somewhat seriously and not merely for
the fun purpose of fun and i know the
judge will agree with me
we may apply it we may misapply it as a
true axon and he may argue that i
misapply it
i have the right on the contrary
to show that i do not
now when he undertakes the show that i
say that because i think this union
cannot exist so permanently so divided
when i say this is so far as a question
of slavery is concerned that i am in
favor of bringing about a dead
uniformity he as i think argues very
erroneously as i will try to show
now the great variations in the local
institution of the states spring from
the differences in their climates and
they're really bonds of union between
the states
each furnishing the mean supply the
walls of the other and they become no
apples of discord
but
can this question of slavery be
assimilated to those things
i leave it to you to say that whether
throughout the history of our government
from time to time
has not this institution of slavery
always failed to be a bond of union but
on the contrary
proved to be an apple of discord and an
element of discord in the house yes
yes
and i ask you to consider whether so
long as a structure of men's mind shall
continue as god sees fit to make them
this question of slavery will not
continue to be an element of discord in
the houses
if that institution is standing in that
position
and it will continue to be an element of
division
if so
if so then i have the right to say that
in regard to that thing
this union is a house divided against
itself
and when the judge remind me as i've
often said to him
that the institution of slavery has
existed for some 80 years in some of the
states
while it does not exist in some of the
others
i agree to the fact
and i explain and account for the fact
by the attitude that our fathers
originally placed it
legislating to put off its source
putting the seal of legislation against
its spread
and leaving the public mind at rest in
the belief that it was in the course
of ultimate extinction
but
i think lately he and those who have
acted with him have placed that
institution on a new basis
one that looks to the perpetuation
and the extension of it
and while it is placed upon this basis i
have said
that i believe that we shall have not
have peace
until either the opponents of rest are
further spread of it and place it for
the public mind shall rest in the
assurance that it is in the courts of
ultimate extinction or
its advocates push it forward
until it becomes a like lawful in all of
the states old as well as new
north as well as south
now let me repeat
if we could arrest the spread of it if
we could place it where washington
jefferson and madison placed it
it would be in the course of ultimate
extinction
and the public mind would be at rest in
the belief of its ultimate extinction
the crisis would pass
and though the institution may be alive
long and might linger for a hundred
years
yet it would be going out in god's own
time
in the way that would be best for both
the white
and
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
do you repudiate popular sovereignty
well
let's talk about popular popular
sovereignty as you insist upon it
what is popular sovereignty a humbug
is it the right of the people to have
slaves or not if they see fit in the
territories well is it or not
i will state that my understanding of
popular sovereignty applied to the
question of slavery and is now applied
does allow the people of a territory to
have slavery if they want it
and it don't allow them not to have it
if they don't want it
i don't mean to say that if this vast
concourse of people were in the
territory of the united states any one
of them would be obliged to have a slave
if they did not want them
but i say that if anyone among them
wants them there is no one or number of
them that can stop him from keeping from
it well you are a fool
well that may be
and i suppose that would make two of us
[Applause]
when i was in springfield that speech of
which the judge complains or from which
he quotes
why i was really not thinking of this
all at all the things he ascribes to me
i had no fault in the world that i was
doing anything to bring about absolute
equality between the white and black
races
it i never occurred to me that i was
doing anything to reduce to a dead
uniformity all the local institutions of
the state
but i must say in justice to the judge
if i am really doing something that
leads to these bad results
it's just as bad to the country whether
i wished it or not
but i ask you
can it be true that placing this
institution of slavery upon the original
basis upon which our fathers placed it
can it have any tendency to compel the
people of vermont to raise sugar cane
because they raise it in louisiana
or can it force the people of the grand
prairie to cut pine logs off the prairie
where none grow
because they cut them in maine
the judge does not generally claim that
he is administering by his kansas
nebraska doctrine the slave question
upon the original constitution
i think he says in one of his speeches
that he saw evidence of a policy
to allow slavery to be in existence
south of a certain line
and to be excluded north of that line
and he heard a disposition of the people
to agree with that policy
and he went about studying it on the
original principles
now
i am fighting him on this original
principle
i am fighting in favor of the old
principles of washington
jefferson and madison
[Applause]
my friends i i want to attend a little
bit more to one or two of these other
things in that springfield speech my
main object was to show so far as my
humble self is capable of doing
to arouse to this country the belief
that there was a tendency
if not a conspiracy
to make slavery perpetual in the
universe in this union
and having made that speech primarily
for that object after bringing forth the
evidence i thought tended to prove that
proposition
among other things i went on with this
bit of a comment
quote
we cannot absolutely know that all these
exact exact adaptations are the result
of pre-concert
but when we see a lot of framed timbers
different portions which we know have
been gotten out of different times and
places by different workmen stephen
franklin
roger and james for instance
and when we see all these timbers join
together
and see they exactly make the frame of a
house or a mill all of the beams and
mortises fitting exactly and all the
lengths and proportions the different
pieces
exactly adapted to their respective
places and not a piece too many
not a piece too few
not even omitting the scaffolding
or if a single piece be liking
we see the place in the frame exactly
fitted and prepared to get such a piece
in
in such a case we find it impossible not
to believe
that stephen
and franklin and roger and james
all understood each other from the
beginning
and all work upon a common plan or a
draft
before the first lick was struck
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
when my friend judge douglas came to
chicago on the 9th of july now this
speech being made delivered was
delivered on the 16th of june
he made a speech there where he took
hold of this speech of mine and showing
that he had carefully read it and while
he paid no attention to this at all
he complimented me as being a most kind
amiable
and intelligent gentleman
notwithstanding i'd said all this he
goes on and draws out from the speech of
mine this tendency to set the states at
war and to set the negroes and the white
people marrying one another
well the next afternoon after that
as the judge had covered me so highly as
he had i i must confess my weakness i
was
i was a little taken with it
i mean after all coming from a great man
and one that the world acknowledges is a
great man and and i do not i do not
speak that in mockery
i was a little taken by it
i'm not much accustomed to flattery
i guess i'm very much like the hoosier
and the gingerbread
he said he loved it better and got less
of it than any other man on earth
well
as the judge had flattered me so much as
he had i made up my mind that he did not
mean to misrepresent me at all
and so i went to making a speech to show
him and to convince him that did i mean
all these dreadful things
as an illustration i had said
incidentally that i claim no right
and there ought to be no incarnation of
the people of the free states to enter
into the slave states and interfere with
the question of slavery at all
the judge thereupon at bloomington when
where i heard him speak
said that i had said that i would not go
into the slave states but that i would
go to the banks of the ohio river and
shoot over among them
well he runs on and on
step by step in the race until he gets
to clinton using this form of speech and
says that quote
unless he shall be successful in firing
his batteries the union shall not stand
unquote
now i don't think this is the way to
treat a kind
amiable
and intelligent gentleman
i thought if i'd asked the judge to show
when or where it was that i had said
that if i did not succeed in firing into
the slave states the union to be
dissolved
he could not do it
i understood well enough he would say
that i did not mean to quote from you i
only admit that this is a result of your
argument
but i have the right to ask and i do now
ask him
did you not put it in the form that any
ordinary listener or a reader of a
newspaper would take it as a quote from
me
but
but i turned in
and in a speech in springfield i thought
i might attend a little to my own
business i recalled as well as i could
his attention to this charge of
conspiracy to nationalize slavery i
called it to his attention and he had
acknowledged he had twice read the
speech and he had made no public plea or
answer i took a default upon him and
insisted that i had the right to renew
the charge of that conspiracy
well
ten days afterwards i met the judge in
clinton that is to say i was on the
ground not in a discussion with him but
i was on the ground to hear him make a
speech
he then comes in with his plea to the
charge for the first time
and his plea when it was put in i
believe as best i can remember amounts
to this
that he never talked to chief justice
tony or the president of the united
states about the dred scott decision
before it was made
and that i lincoln or to know that the
man who makes a charge not knowing it to
be true
falsifies as much as he who knows it to
be false
and lastly
he would pronounce the whole thing of
falsehood but he made no personal
application the charge of falsehood
not out of regard for the kind amiable
gentleman
but his own personal self-respect
i have understood since
but i won't stick it to the judge
if he doesn't want me to
he has come up to saying the thing out
the judge nice to me that it's so
now it may astonish you that i can keep
such a good humor as i can when the
judge acknowledges that he's making a
question of veracity with me
i know that the judge is a great man
and i a small one
but i feel in my soul i have got him on
this one
[Applause]
[Music]
now i wave all objection because it
wasn't filed until after default was
taken
and i had to murder to it on its merits
what if judge douglas never did talk to
chief justice tawny or the president
until the decision was made
does it follow the could not have as a
perfect understanding with them without
it as with it
but
i'm disposed to take as a denial rather
as a answer in chancellory that he
neither had knowledge or the belief of
the existence of such a conspiracy
and now i ask you that after that's
denied if he had done so had i not the
right yet to prove it on him and is
there not more than the evidence of the
two witnesses to prove it and if it does
not prove the existence of a conspiracy
does it disturb the facts at all that
would run to show
that he was being used by the
conspirators instead of being the leader
of them
[Applause]
now in regard
in regard to his reminding me of the
moral rule that people who tell what
they do not know to be true falsify as
much as though who knowingly tell a
falsehood i remember that rule
and it should be born in mind that what
i've read to you
says that i do not know such a
conspiracy be true
but i say that i believe it and if he
says i don't believe it then he says
that thing that he don't know and he
falls within his own rule
as to his statement that if it weren't
for his self-respect he would call the
whole thing a falsehood
or in plainer words called somebody a
liar about it
i want to call your attention to a
little discussion about that branch of
the case
i had arrayed the evidence which brought
my mind to the conclusion
now if in stating that that evidence by
mistake any part of it be erroneous
it needed the judge to have pointed it
out to me because i would have taken it
back
if if i had brought forth anything as a
matter of fact that was not a matter of
fact and he should point it out to me it
wouldn't ruffle me to take it back
and if he will point it out to me or
show that i have reason falsely
it is not for him to call the kind
amiable gentleman a liar
if i have reason to a false conclusion
it is but the vocation of a very able
debater
to show the fact in a very amiable way
without any cross or ugly language
it's easily done
but i want to ask this attention to the
audience to a portion of the nebraska
bill which the judge himself has quoted
it being the true intent and meaning of
this act not to legislate slavery to any
territory or state
but to leave the people thereof
perfectly free to regulate their own
domestic institutions in their own way
subject only to the federal constitution
instantly the judge thereupon starts
arguing in favor of popular sovereignty
the right of the people to have slaves
if they want them and to exclude slavery
if they wanted to do so
but
says a senator from ohio by the name of
chase
we more than suspect that you do not
mean the people shall have the right to
exclude slavery if they want to
and if you do mean it
accept an amendment expressly
authorizing the people to exclude
slavery
i believe i have the amendment here
before me
the people of the territory through
their appropriate representations may
if they see fit
prohibit the existence of slavery
therein
now
i stated as a fact to be taken back if
there is any mistake about it
that judge douglas
and those acting with him
voted that amendment down
[Applause]
now
i now think that those men who voted
that down had a real reason for doing so
they know what the reason was
it looks to us since we have seen the
dred scott decision come
holding that under the constitution the
people cannot exclude slavery
it looks to outsiders
poor
kind amiable intelligent gentleman
it looks as if the police were left for
the dread scottish position to be put in
and i now say if there's another or a
different reason other the conclusion i
have drawn
it will avail the judge
much more to point out to these people
what good reason there was for boating
that amendment down
rather than swelling himself up and
asserting that he may be provoked to
call somebody a liar
again
[Applause]
again there isn't that same quotient
quotation from the nebraska bill another
point
it being the true intended meaning of
this act not to legislate slavery into
any territory or
state i've always been puzzled but why
the word state was placed there
now judge douglas knows
he put it there and he knows what he put
it there for
we outsiders could not see
what it was being put there for the law
that they were passing was not about
states it was making no provision for
states
what was it put there for
after seeing the dred scott decision
if another shall come holding if they
cannot exclude it from the states
we will find that it was the odd half of
something
the other half was which to come in due
time
i now say again
if there is a different reason for
putting it there
the judge
in a good humored way without calling me
or anybody else a liar
tell what that good reason was
[Applause]
when the judge spoke at clinton he was
very near making a charge of falsehood
against me
he used as i find it printed in
newspapers and afterwards as well i can
remember it the language was very early
if not the same the following words
i did not answer the charge before for
the reason that i did not suppose there
was an american whose heart was so
corrupt
as for a moment to believe such a charge
to be true we knew it to be true didn't
we
and then the judge after i've dropped a
part of the quotation added that he had
too much respect for mr lincoln to
suppose
that he was serious in making the charge
i confess i thought it a curious view
that i was making what he now says was a
serious charge
in fun
now says the judge i did not for a
moment believe that there was a man in
america whose heart was so corrupt as to
make such a charge
i hope the judge will not blame me for
bringing for being the only man in
america who has a heart base enough to
make such a charge
i hope that he will excuse me if i find
one other
and that other one happened to be judge
douglas himself
why then i hope he will consider his
question of the deep corruption of heart
that he has felt thought fit to ascribe
to me
in douglas's speech
on the 22nd of march 1858 i read
in this connection there is another
topic which i desire to elude
i seldom refer to the course of the
newspapers or notice the articles which
they publish in regard to myself
but the course of the washington union
has been so extraordinary for the last
two or three months that i think it well
enough to make some allusion to it
it has read me out of the democratic
party every other day at least for two
or three months and keeps reading me out
and it if it has not succeeded still
continues to read me out using such
terms as traitor deserter deserter
and other such kind and polite
things of that nature
sir i have the vindication to make of my
democracy against the washington union
or any other newspaper
i am willing to allow my history in
action for the last 20 years to speak
for themselves as to my political
principles and my fidelity to my
political obligations
the washington union has a personal
grievance when its editor was nominated
for public printer i declined to vote
for him and stated that for some time
later i might give my reason for doing
so
since i declined to give that both this
squirrel's abuse these vindictive and
constant attacks have been repeated on
me almost daily
there is one article an issue of that
paper which i asked my friend from
michigan to read
now ladies and gentlemen this
this this speech was made on the 22nd of
march 1858 and this part begins on page
21. and i tell you the places that you
may read the article which stewart reads
for judge douglas
now when he gets through reading judge
douglas sums up as i think correctly
the views advanced by the washington
union
mr president
you see several distinct propositions
advanced bully by the washington union
editorially
and apparently authentically
that every man who questions any of them
is denounced as an abolitionist
a free soiler and a fanatic
these propositions are first that the
primary object of all government is
original institution
is the protection of persons and
property
and second
that the constitution of the united
states declares that the citizens of
each state
shall be entitled to all the privileges
and immunities of the citizens of the
several states
and
therefore thirdly
all state property and especially
declaring it forfeited are direct
violations of the original intentions of
the government and the constitution of
the united states
and fourth the emancipation of the
slaves of the northern states was a
gross outrage on the rights of property
and so much it was involuntarily done on
the part of the owner
remember this article was published on
the in the union on the 17th of november
and on the 18th of november appeared the
first article
giving adhesion to the union
of the union
to the lecompton constitution
it was in these words
kansas and her constitution
the vexed question is settled
the problem is solved
the dread point of danger is passed
all serious to all serious trouble to
kansas affairs is over
and done
and a column nearly of the same sort
then when you come to look into the
lecompton constitution
you will find the same doctrine
incorporated into it that was first put
forth editorially in the union
quote
it can be seen by these clauses in the
lecompton constitution that they are
identical in spirit
with this article in the washington
union of that day
of the day previous to its endorsement
of this constitution
and every man is branded as a free
soiler an abolitionist who does not
subscribe to them
and it ends with this
when i saw that article in the union on
the 17th of november
followed by the glorification of the
lecompton constitution on the 18th of
november
and this clause in the constitution
asserting that the doctrine that no
state had a right to prohibit slavery
within its limits
i saw there a fatal blow being struck at
the sovereignty of the states of this
union
and a death blow to states right
subversive to the democratic platform
and the principles upon which the
democratic party has ever stood
and upon which i wish it will ever stand
in quote
now
what is this charge that the judge
thinks i must be making to be so corrupt
and have such a corrupt heart to have
made
it is the purpose of the state to
prohibit the citizens of other states
coming into that state
and settling down with their slave
property
in other words
it was a conspiracy
now i want to ask you attention to
something the judge has done
i know that he made this speech
authenticity as a reason they refuse to
vote for a certain man as a public
printer
but when it gets to the charge is it not
the same charge i made against him
does he make it against the newspaper
editorially merely
if that is a identical in spirit with
the compton constitution so that the
frameworks of the constitution are
brought in with the editor of that
newspaper in that fatal blow being
struck
now he does not call it a conspiracy
in his language it is a
fatal blow being struck
[Laughter]
and he may if the word be any better
change the word i used into a fatal blow
being struck
but we see the charges that the fatal
blow is not being struck by the editor
of the union
but by the framers of the lecompton
constitution
but also that the article is by whose
authority is whose authority is it being
made
who does he mean
it is by the authority of the president
and the government the administration
is there any question that this is so
where is the editor of the union the
framers of the lecompton constitution
the president and all the supporters of
the lecompton constitution in congress
and out of it are all involved in this
charge of douglas
of a fatal blow being struck to
nationalize slavery
i commend him the consideration of the
question is how corrupt a heart
a man must make
to be having make such a charge
[Applause]
and now my friends i have but one other
branch of this subject in the limited
time we have to speak and i shall touch
upon it i have been one branch to which
i will call your attention
and then i shall come to a close
it is probable that i shall not occur
occupy all the time that belongs to me
and though i would like to talk twice as
long
i ask the attention of this community
here assembled and everywhere else to
the course that judge douglas is
pursuing every day
upon this question of making slavery
national
not going back to the record but going
to the speeches that he has made here
and elsewhere
i asked attention to that
in the first place what is necessary to
make the institution of slavery national
there is no danger that the people of
kentucky are going to shoulder their
muskets to bring slavery upon us
there is no danger of us going over
there to make war on them
dare not do it
what is necessary to make slavery
national
it's simply the next dred scott decision
it is simply for the supreme court to
declare
that no state under the constitution
can exclude slavery
just as they
and the territorial legislators cannot
exclude from the limits of the territory
this being true
this being the way i think that slavery
will be made national
if it is ever to be made so at all
let us consider what judge douglas is
doing first let us say that public
sentiment is everything
he who molds public sentiment is greater
than he who makes the statutes
this born in mind
and also the fact that my friend douglas
my friend judge douglas is is a man of
vast influence
and it is enough for many men to
progress to believe a thing
so that when one finds out that he
professes or believes it
they take it as part of their creed
this is the attitude of the party which
is perhaps as he claims the majority
party
and who will agree with his sentiments
in a public campaign
this being born in mine
what does a judge do in regard to the
dred scott decision
he sticks to a decision that forbids the
people of a territory to exclude slavery
not because he says it's right in itself
but because it's been decided by a court
and because it comes from that court
he as a good citizen and you as good
citizens are bound
to take it into your political actions
not that he judges it on its merits but
because of the season accord to him is a
thus
saith the lord
there is nothing there is nothing that
can turn the judge away from his
devotion to this decision
it is not enough that i should point out
to him this great prototype jackson did
not believe in this way about the great
binding towards the supreme court
decisions
it is not that i point out to him that
jefferson didn't believe in it
i have said that i have heard the judge
himself often approve of the opinion of
jackson
but i say that he ought to remember
better than i
and i will make no question with him
but it seems to me that i heard i've
heard him say at least at 20 times
and i will tell him that although he
claims
to stand on the cincinnati platform and
that the cincinnati platform asserts
that congress cannot charter a national
bank in the teeth of the decision of the
supreme court
that congress can charter a national
bank
i will also
i will also remind him a piece of
illinois history which can be found in
forgery history of illinois of the time
when the respected party to which the
judge belongs was displaced or was
displeased with the decision of the
supreme court of illinois
because they had decided the governor
could not remove secretary of state
and he will not deny that he went in for
over slaughtering that court by
appointing five new judges
[Applause]
[Music]
and
it ended in his getting his name of
judge that very way
that's breaking down the supreme court
and when he tells me how a man shall be
appointed on such a principle by me
questions
i say judge
you know
you've tried it
and when he seeks to say that the court
will be prosecuted below contempt
i say judge
you ought to know you've been through
the mill once
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and when i speak these things
but although when i speak these things i
cannot make the judge fall loose from
his adherence to the dred scott decision
if i may say so
and by this i i mean no disrespect
he's like some creature that will hang
on
under which he's got his hole to a thing
and you can cut off his arms and you can
cut off his limbs and he's still hanging
on
he is bespattered from the beginning of
his life with war upon the courts
and at last
he hangs on with desperation
the dread scott decision
[Applause]
does this not show that there is a
purpose for which he adheres to that
decision
upon a principle that will make him
appear
to all other decisions
coming from the same court
[Music]
give us something besides the dred scott
decision
now
no doubt you would rather hear something
that don't hurt you
now
one more matter haven't spoken this red
scott decision mr clay
my bow ideal of a great statesman
a man for whom i have fought all my
humble life
mr clay once said of a class of man who
he supposed
would repress all tendency to ultimate
emancipation
that they must if they were to do this
go back to the hour of our own
liberty and independence
and muzzle the cannon that thunders its
annual joyous return
and that they must blow out the moral
lights around us
and they must pervert the human soul
and they must eradicate the human soul
and the love of liberty
and then
and not until then
could they perpetuate slavery in this
country
[Applause]
[Music]
to my thinking
judge douglas is now
by his example and best influence
doing that very thing
in this community
when
when he is saying that the negro has no
share in the declaration of independence
he is going back to the year of our
revolution
and his to the extent of his ability
he is muzzling the cannon that thunders
its annual joyous return
when he is saying as often he has said
that if any people want slavery they
have a right to have it
he is blowing out the moral lights
around us
when he says that he don't care whether
slavery is voted down or voted up into
my thinking
he is so far as he able to do
perverting the human soul
and eradicating the light of reason
and the love of liberty on the american
continent
[Applause]
and when he shall have succeeded in
bringing the public sentiment
to the exact accordance of his own
when this vast assemblage goes back with
these sentiments instilled into them
it needs only the formality
of a second dred scott decision which he
is in favor of
to make slavery alike lawful in all of
the states
old as well as new
north as well as south alright
[Applause]
[Music]
my friends
that ends the chapter
ted's douglas may take his 30 minutes
three cheers
[Applause]
[Applause]
lincoln's
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
i will now occupy the half hour allotted
to me
in reply to mr lincoln
the first point to which i will call
your attention
is what i said about the organization
of the republican party in 1854 and the
platform that was formed on the 5th
october of that year
and then i put the question to mr
lincoln
whether or not he approved of each
article that platform
said that already i have told him that i
should call for a specific answer to
each of these interrogatories
i do not charge him with being a member
of the committee that reported the
platform i charge that that platform was
the platform of the republican party and
adopted by them
the fact that it was the platform of the
republican party
is not now denied
but mr lincoln now says that although
his name was on the committee that he
don't think he was there he thinks
he thinks he wasn't as well holding
cords
how do you think this is absurd let's
give mr douglas the same consideration
we gave to mr lincoln he had a right to
speak now mr douglas has a right to
speak
i ask your silence
and no interruption
i want to remind mr lincoln of the fact
that he was there and i will remind him
of the fact
the point is this
that after i had made my speech in
springfield in 54 during the affair
he gave me notice that he was going to
reply to me on the next day
after the notice
i was sick at the time and i stayed over
to hear his reply to me and to reply to
him
on that day
this very convention of which he speaks
was to meet in the senate chamber while
he was speaking in the house
and when he got through his speech my
recollection is distinct that mr ichabob
cutting walked in
and as i took the stand to reply
gave notice that the republican
convention would meet instantly in the
senate chamber and called upon the
republicans the republicans to go into
this convention instead of listening to
me
yeah yeah well mr lincoln says let him
add that he went along with them
i will not add that for i do not know
that
but
whether he knows it or not is not my
point
and yeah i will yet bring him to his
milk on this point
in the first place
mr lincoln was selected by the very men
who made the republican organization
that day to make a speech and reply to
me a speech for that party
he was
the leader of that party and on the very
day that he made a speech there in reply
to me preaching up the same doctrine of
the declaration of independence that
[ __ ] were equal to white men that
very day
this republican convention meant their
three cheers for douglas
[Applause]
that convention waited on him after its
time of meeting to hear mr lincoln's
speech and then cudding the leading man
marched in and gave notice the moment
lincoln was through that they would
proceed for they did not want to hear me
in reply
another fact that i have here
a newspaper printed in springfield this
is lincoln's own town in october 54 a
few days afterwards publishing these
resolutions and charging mr lincoln is
entertaining those sentiments and also
trying to prove that mr richard yates
the candidate for congress did those
have been published on lincoln again and
again and never before has he denied it
but
but my friends
this
this thing of denial about acting on the
committee
is miserable quibble to avoid the main
issue
the main issue is that this republican
platform declares
in favor of the unconstitutional repeal
of the fugitive slave law
has mr lincoln answered that question no
i called his attention to it and i
predicted that he would not answer it
and how does he answer it he answers by
saying
i wasn't on the committee that wrote it
talking to him distinctly whether
if the people of the territory when they
had sufficient population to make a
state
should make a state recognizing slavery
in it he would vote for against
admission
he is a candidate of the united states
senate it is possible if elected that he
would have a vote directly on this
question
i asked him to answer me and you whether
he would vote to admit a state into the
union with slavery or without as its own
people might choose
he has not answered that has he
[Applause]
he has not answered that question he has
judged that question under the cover of
saying he wasn't on the committee at the
time he wasn't present when the platform
was made well i want to know if he were
present in the senate when the state
applies for admission with the
constitution acceptable to its own
people will he admit the state if it
asks
he avoids the question and at the same
time he gives the abolitionists to
understand by a hint
that he would not vote to admit such a
state
why
why he says that a man who would talk
about each state having slavery as it
pleased
was akin to a man who would muzzle the
press of the revolution
he says that that kind of talk is
blighting the glory of this country
now
what is the meaning of that
the meaning is that he is not in favor
of each state doing as it pleased on the
slavery questions
[Applause]
[Music]
and i want to screw it out of him
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
again
this platform which was made at
springfield by his own party when he was
its acknowledged head
proves
that they will go for abolishing slavery
in the district of columbia
i asked mr lincoln specifically whether
he will do that or not yet did you get
an answer from him
no
he is afraid to answer
he knows i will try him down to egypt
i intend to make him answer there as
well as here
and i intend to show the people of
illinois that his object is not to
answer on these points that's right
right
[Applause]
again
they go on further and pledge themselves
to exclude slavery from all the
territories over which the general
government has exclusive jurisdiction
north of 36 degrees 30 minutes as well
as south and south as well as north
now
i want to know whether he is for that
prohibition
when he answers them i want to know his
opinion on the further porn
further point whether he will redeem
the pledge of this platform to arrest
the acquisition of any more territory
unless the practice of slavery shall
have been therein forever prohibited i
want him to answer that last question
each and all of these questions
they are
practical questions questions upon which
the republican party was formed
they
are the fundamental principles of the
party and i want to know if he is the
unanimous the first last and only choice
of that party with whom he don't agree
in principle
now he don't deny but what the man who
is not faithful to it
is faithless to the republican party
well i want to know whether the
republican party
are unanimously in favor of a man who
don't adopt their creed and won't agree
with them in their principles i want to
know whether a man who is afraid to avow
that he is with them is the first last
and only choice of the republican party
[Applause]
oh the conspiracy never mind i will come
to that soon enough
but
the platform not only lays down this
but also has the resolution
that in furtherance of these principles
we will use such constitutional and
lawful means
as shall seem best adapted to their
accomplishment
and that
we will support no man for office
under the general or state government
who is not positively and fully
committed to the support of these
principles and whose personal character
and conduct is not a guarantee that he
is reliable
and who shall not have juror dog party
illusions and ties
[Applause]
now the republican party stands pledged
that they will never support mr lincoln
till he has given pledges for that
platform
[Music]
and he cannot devise an answer he has
not made up his mind whether he will or
not
oh he talked about everything else he
could think of in order to occupy his
hour and a half
and when he could not think of anything
more to say in order to get an excuse
for refusing to answer these questions
he sat down before his time was up
and told you so
[Applause]
now
now about this charge of conspiracy
mr lincoln today goes on and quotes a
part of his speech a playful part of it
about stephen and james and franklin and
roger et cetera
and said
that i did not take exception to that
and did not answer
he repeats that again
that was not what i took exception to
he has a right to use these playful
words
and throws words together as much as he
pleases
what i took exception to was this
afterwards
he made a speech in which he said
he intended that speech
as a charge of corruption and conspiracy
between the judges of the supreme court
president pierce president buchanan and
myself now that gave the offensive
character to the charge
he then said that when he made it he did
not know whether it was true or not
but
but he said that inasmuch as judge
douglas had not denied it
although i'd replied to the other parts
of the speech three times
he now repeated the charge of conspiracy
on judge douglas
and thus
turned it
into a charge of moral turpitude
and when he put it in that form
i did not say that
and in as much as he repeated the charge
merely because i did not deny it he did
it on my silence not knowing it to be
true
i would deprive him of the opportunity
of ever repeating again by saying it was
in all its bearings an
infamous lie
[Applause]
he says he will repeat it until i will
get into answering his folly
about frank and bob and john
he studied that out and prepared that
one sentence and committed it to memory
to put in his speech at springfield
and carries it around now and reads it
to the audience to hear how pretty it is
his vanity is offended because i won't
go into that beautiful passage about
building the house
[Laughter]
all i have to say is i am not green
enough to let him make a charge
which he acknowledges he did not know to
be true
and then take up the whole of my time
and answering a charge which i know to
be false and nobody knows to be true
[Applause]
i have not
brought a charge of moral turpitude
against him
and when he
or any other living man bring one
against me
instead of putting myself on the proof
and just proving it i will say
it is alive
i have lived 25 years
i have lived 25 years in illinois
i have served you with all the fidelity
and ability i know how.
and
and he is at liberty to attack by public
horse and sections
attack my views and conduct
but when he attacks my moral integrity
by a charge of conspiracy between me and
justice tawny and the two re presidents
i repel it great cheers
[Applause]
mr lincoln has not character enough for
integrity and truth
merely on his own ipsy dixit to arraign
president buchanan and president pierce
and the judges of the supreme court
any one of whom would not be
complimented if put on a level with mr
lincoln
there is an unpardonable presumption in
a man
putting himself before thousands of
people
and pretending to think that his ipsa
dixit without proof or fact or evidence
or truth
is enough to break down the character of
the purest
and the best of living men
i must pass on
[Music]
my time is escaping
mr lincoln wants to know why i voted
against chase's amendment to the
nebraska bill
i tell him
in the first place the bill already
conferred all the power which congress
had
by giving them the whole power over the
subject
then
then chase offered a proviso that they
might abolish slavery which by
implication would carry the idea that
they could prohibit but could not
introduce it
general cass i think proposed to modify
it so they might either introduce or
prohibit slavery and make it fair and
equal
chase refused to modify it in that form
and then cass and all the rest of us
voted it down
[Applause]
these facts appear in the journals and
the debates where mr lincoln found the
charge
and if he had told the truth
there would be no necessity for me to
occupy your time in explaining the
charge
mr lincoln
wants to know why the word state
as well as as territory
is put in the nebraska bill
i tell him
it was put there by me
particularly to meet such false
arguments as he has been introducing
that not only the territory should do as
it pleased but that the state should
that is it should come in as a state
with or without slavery as it pleased
i need to knock in the head these
abolition doctrines of his that there
should be no more slave states even if
the people wanted them
and it won't do for mr lincoln and the
republicans to say that nobody's against
the doctrine of there being any more
slave states
what
is the cause
of the missouri compromise
the people of missouri formed a
constitution as a slave state
and asked for admission
and the free soil party being in the
majority voted her out of the union
because she had slavery
hence
this this first slavery agitation arose
upon a state
and not upon a territory and yet mr
lincoln don't know why the word state
was there
the whole abolition agitation
arose out of that doctrine of
prohibiting the state
from entering in with slavery or without
as it pleased
and that question is now in this
republican platform of 54 never been
repealed yet and every republican stands
pledged by the platform
never to vote for any man who is not in
favor of that platform
and yet mr lincoln does not know that
there are men in the world opposed to
admitting a state with slavery if they
want it
at the same time that this platform says
that they won't receive a state under
these circumstances
now
my friends
you see that on these very points
i am as far from bringing lincoln to the
line as i ever was before
he did not want to avow his principles
i do want to proclaim mine
as sunlight
in mid-may
the democrats and principles are formed
a democracy is formed in the eternal
principles of truth
the plainer those principles are avowed
the stronger the support they will
receive
i only wish i had the power to make them
so clear
that they would shine in the heavens for
every man woman and child to
[Applause]
and the read principles that i would
proclaim
would be in opposition to mr lincoln's
doctrines of uniformity between the
institutions of the different states
and i would declare in lieu of it the
sovereign right of each state to decide
the slavery question as well as all
other questions for themselves without
interference from any other state or
power whatsoever
[Applause]
when
you will recognize that principle
you will have peace and harmony and
fraternity between all the different
states of the union
till you do recognize that doctrine
there will be a sectional warfare
agitating and disturbing the peace of
this country
what
does mr lincoln propose
he says
the union cannot exist divided into free
enslaved states
if it cannot endure dust thus divided
then he must strive to make them all
free
or all slave or be for a dissolution
[Applause]
i am told that my time is up
and stop therefore
[Applause]
energy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
thank
please
[Music]
thank you
thank you
thank you thank you very much
thank you
thank you
thank you
thank you
thank you
god bless you thank you
thank you the honorable congressman
thank you joy yeah
after the debate thank you in 1858 thank
you let's give a nice welcome to
congressman lovejoy but also tonight
from six to eight the first brigade band
will present a concert here of civil war
music bring your lawn chairs and have a
lovely evening in the park i hope the
weather holds up it's been a great day
mr lovejoy congressman lovejoy you're on
come over to our site
[Music]
they say lovejoy took off his coat and
his thigh and he went at it and i want
to give you a 14-minute dose of owen
lovejoy the congregational minister from
princeton
well the first debate is over the first
of seven lincoln douglas debates
c-span's special coverage
this summer and into the fall
will continue next weekend in freeport
illinois for debate number two which
actually will be a little longer than
this one this one finished early it's
only two hours and 15 minutes the
original debate was about 15 minutes
early which was about 2 hours and 45
minutes long at that time so
the gentleman
portraying both lincoln and douglas